The fundamental idea behind the firm timer
design is to provide accurate timing with very
low overhead. And what it does is it combines the good points of the one shot
timer and the soft timers. As I mentioned, the one shot timer, its virtue is the
fact that we can have the timer interrupt
happen exactly at the time that we want.
In other words, we get rid of
the timer inaccuracy that we mentioned earlier. That
plagues normal timer design in general purpose operating
systems. The con that we said with the
oneshot timer, is that there is overhead
associated with processing oneshot timer events. As well
as reprogramming them. So for that reason, what
they do in TS Linux with the firm
timer design is to have a knob, which is
called the overshoot knob, and the idea is the
one shot timer expired here. This is the point
at which the event happened, but what we're going
to do is. We're going to have a parameter
associated with the one shot timer called the overshoot
parameter and what that overshoot parameter is allowing you
to do is, even though this is the point
at which the event happened, the one-shot timer is
programmed to go off at this point. So there
is a distance between the actual event happening and
the point at which the one-shot timer has been programmed
to interrupt the CPU. This is the overshoot parameter.
You may wonder, what is the advantage of this
overshoot parameter? Well, within this overshoot parameter window, there
could be a system call, which is a soft interrupt.
We mentioned that applications typically make system
calls, or there could be an external interrupt.
Any of those things can bring you into the kernel, and so you may be already
in the kernel at this point during this
overshoot window. So what we could do now
is, we'll dispatch the expired timers at this
point of time and also we will reprogram
the one-shot timer that expired for the next time
that we need the one-shot timer to interrupt. Normally, the
one shot timer would have gone off here because
this is the overshoot window, but even before that, since
the system call happened, at this point, we'll going to
see that oh, there is this one shot timer that
has already expired, its going to interrupt me not in
the too distant future, might as well dispatch that expired
timer right now and reprogram that one shot timer so that it is now ready
for the next one-shot timer interrupt. The upshot
of doing this, dispatching the expired timer at
the point of the system call that
is happening within this overshoot window, is that
at the point at which this one-shot timer
has been programmed to interrupt, that is gone.
It'll not cause an interrupt because we've reprogrammed
this one-shot timer to interrupt at the next one-shot
timer expiry event. Because whatever action that needed to
be taken with respect to this particular one-shot timer
expiration has already been taken at this point
and therefore at this point we will not get
another interrupt. So we have saved on the one-shot
timer interrupt that would have happened at this point
of time by combining the hard and soft
timer in this manner. I mentioned that fielding
a one-shot timer interrupt is expensive. We avioded
that. Because, fielding the interrupt happened as part
of handling the system call and at this
point itself, we have re-programmed the one-shot timer
for the next event as well. So you can see that the firm timer design combines
the good points of both the one-shot timer as well as the soft timer. It is
giving us the accuracy that we want from
the one-shot timer but at the same time, we
are avoiding the overhead associated with one-shot timer
by processing that interrupt using this over shoot
parameter. Of course, with, within this over shoot
parameter, there is no system call or external interrupt
that brings us into the kernel, then we will have this one-shot timer
going off at this point. But the hope is that by choosing this
knob appropriately, between hard and soft timers, we can make sure that we
reduce the number of times we get
the one shot timer interrupts actually occurring.